igniting chaos for a great cause this
saturday at chaos at the palms is the
burn foundation's bachelor auction and
these firefighters are fighting for your
hearts let's welcome nino galloway with
the burn foundation also a north las
vegas firefighter yes with us right now
so first and foremost let's talk about
this hot ticket
who are the bachelors you have with us
we have ben and carl uh i want you to
introduce us in your best game show
voice all right ladies and gentlemen
we are here to talk about the most
amazing event that's going to happen in
the month of july in las vegas we have
two amazing firefighters we have ben and
carl
firefighters in southern nevada here and
this guy right here
used to dance for a couple of
shows he was a performer in a few shows
on the street
so you know what you're doing i i got my
first radio
it comes with the it comes with the
accent too
that's right we love that okay so how
many bachelors and bachelorettes are
gonna be on stage yeah so we're gonna be
auctioning off 16
uh firefighters uh five 15 men one
female along with six fire station
dinners which are always a big hit
awesome and how does the auction
actually work
what goes into this break it down for us
all right
so but keep it simple it's it's a great
event that helps us raise some funds but
what we do is the ladies come out buy a
ticket have some fun uh about
an hour into the fun
our auctioneer christian colbert will
take over and he's gonna auction off the
firefighters after they perform their
skits so some are singing some are
dancing uh some are playing uh
instruments uh some are just tossing
roses
and
we we ask them to be creative and
they've got the gamut i love that so
there's so it's you know it's
action-packed there's entertainment you
guys are performing um what else can
what else are you getting with this
ticket got it so one is you're gonna
help these firefighters all of us are
here to represent this event uh we've
got a dj that's gonna be playing music
great mc's uh brian chan sarah leclear
and uh you are going to have an amazing
night of dancing fun a little bit of
champagne maybe a lot of champagne maybe
a lot of champagne and then after after
the event whoever you know wins the bid
what happens for them well they win the
auction package
and then they have the option of asking
the firefighter to join them for the
date okay okay so we have options we've
got great package we have great packages
we have staycations we have show tickets
awesome uh helicopter flights uh there's
a trip to cabo woo
and it's all going for a really great
cause really quick to to in this um the
burn foundation's mission those four
initiatives that you guys are going to
be getting money for we've had a chance
to talk about so basically what we do is
we help we help people after we've run
the call right so we see these
catastrophic incidents it was our way of
helping them after it's out we do the
annual toy drive where we help a lot
thousands of kids each and every year
we have a burn survivor initiative where
we support and uh help those that have
have been burned as well as reduce burns
with our flip flops
and then our last one is to really
provide some prevention tips okay well
thank you nina for everything you guys
are doing as you know as firefighters
first and foremost but then of course
for our burn victims as well awesome all
right thank you okay again that is the
burn foundation.org ignite chaos
bachelor auction this saturday the ninth
seven to eleven like i said it's a hot
ticket
all right julie johnson to you all right